foreign
ation when I had my daughter she tells a
lot of people
I don't have a dad like random people I
almost feel like she mom shamed me I
don't want to feel like she's missing
out on anything but she is I mean she's
missing out on a dad right
[Music]
what up what up this is John with the Dr
John deloney show
what many claim and by many I mean me
and my mom
claim to be the greatest mental health
and marriage and parenting podcast ever
ever
is that overstated probably by about 97
but listen we're gonna keep saying it
because we want it to be true
just like America so dude I'm so glad
that you've joined us on this show we
talk about
these are colored it's caller driven you
guys call and we're dealing with your
mental health we're dealing with what's
going on your relationships we're
dealing with parenting issues with
what's going on in local schools we're
dealing with all of it so anything
that's going on in your world give me a
buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 and my promises I'll get
down in the mud with you and we will sit
down and figure this thing out and um
I'm so grateful that you called before
we take the first call
everybody
we blew all of yesterday's show talking
about Taylor Swift concert and we didn't
call out the most important thing
Grandma Kelly had a birthday I really
hate you sometimes you are three years
younger than me 17 years younger than
you three Seventeen math is not your
strong suit that's why you're doing this
show this is but congratulations what'd
you get thank you nothing from me
because I didn't know about it yeah and
none
um my husband gave me what I always ask
for which is gift cards so I can go
shopping no I love shopping with other
people's money where did Andrew get you
oh nothing
yeah Jenna
it's on the way can't say oh you're well
a you're a rapper now because you're
rhyming and B unbelievable
yes but yeah I've heard it was a rather
big one on Saturday a Sunday like well
the year before a big birthday
I know 70. God Almighty seriously no the
only reason you can say that is because
there's glass between you and Kelly and
cause I'm correct I'm good I'm good I
turned 49 thank you very much
49. wow and I'm just
destroying this place all right let's
take a hey Happy Birthday Kelly
on behalf of those of us who struggle to
count that high we are happy to have you
as still alive in our life let's go out
to Abigail in not South but North Little
Rock what's up Abigail
um you're breaking up try that one again
oh what about now much better much
better how we doing
I'm doing good I do have to say I was at
the Taylor Swift concert on Sunday here
in Nashville
yes it was the best and the worst why
was it why was it the worst we all know
why it was the best but why was it the
worst because of the lightning and the
rain we were stuck in the stadium for
four hours
whoa did they cancel this I mean did
they stop the show they did she played
from 10 P.M to 1 30 A.M
dude that's dedication right there can
we just yeah did y'all stay the night in
Nashville do you have to drive all the
way back to Arkansas
so we stayed and we
um early the next morning we were
running on three hours of sleep hey some
things are worth it like the birth of a
child the death of a parent and Taylor
Swift
they
oh you just made Jenna's whole day
there's a whole oh my gosh y'all are wow
okay so what's up how can I help
all right so my question is how do you
know in our relationship if you're just
too different to make it work
tell me more
okay so I have noticed that I have a
habit of dating people that are
struggling with emotional regulation and
occasionally addiction and my job is
also a therapist
awesome and so I tend to see the best in
people and always see people for their
per like for their potential and so I
just can't tell when in a relationship
I'm staying and I'm being supportive of
someone in a rough season or when maybe
they need time to grow and mature on
their own
I don't know I'm kind of struggling with
that Dynamic of like when to walk away
and when you know that someone's ready
for a relationship I guess
okay so two questions one when you say I
always see the best in people that is
often code for
I need them to be this certain way in my
fantasy world because I can't live in a
world where people are x y and z
is that fair or is that not like you can
say do this that's not true at all
I mean possibly I feel like um
I'm a pretty open-minded and
understanding person but I keep on I
don't know how but I keep on dating
people with anger issues and I think
that's one of my biggest triggers as
well in a relationship who had anger
issues in your life growing up
um
maybe my mom my dad was the opposite of
that to where he was very passive and
not very emotionally available but he
was there doing things like the physical
aspects like paying the bills and
changing the oil to my car
um and he was like the fun person to
hang out with but my mom I would say was
mostly the one that was in charge and
was always kind of having to be the bad
cop too so when you say he was fun to
hang around with but he was not
emotionally available pull that apart
for me
like watching movies or going on like a
week-long trip around the United States
but whenever it would come to any type
of deeper conversation he would just
kind of feel awkward and shut down and
not really know what to say so anything
kind of
emotion related that's something that I
would always go to my mom for gotcha so
I have found over and over and over
again
non-scientifically I haven't found any
studies that support this but it just is
one of those things that keeps showing
up as a truth
um that we marry our unfinished business
um we either
you're trying to solve mom's anger like
why was she so mad with me and your body
continually finds people that you are
going to be in relationship with that
have that same
pulsing nuclear reactor core in their
chest and you set off to try to solve it
and you are do that through thinking the
best of people or wishing the best about
people or fantasizing their their they
could be this one day or your body's
trying to connect with somebody in some
meaningful way and often people who are
angry a lot are emotional a lot and
people who are emotional a lot can also
be incredibly loving when that machine
is turned off either way your body's
trying to solve a problem that it has
been trying to solve for a long long
time and that's why you find yourself in
this dating Loop this this pattern over
and over and over again if the people
look different they have different jobs
but at the core they're still struggling
with the same thing that sets your
body's alarms off right
mm-hmm I
give me an example there's a reason you
called why did you call did something
happen recently
yes so uh do you have a lover that is so
mad you went to Taylor Swift if so get
rid of it no absolutely not he would not
be accepted
all right so what is it
um so I have been married before
um I've been divorced coming up on a
year and whenever I'm married I think
looking back I married him based on the
potential of what he could be so he
struggled with anger issues and
struggles with addiction and he said
that he wanted to change and wanted to
get help
um and then whenever we started living
together after we got married I feel
like a lot of things came out of the
woodwork and I sat down and I said you
know I need this from you to feel safe I
don't feel emotionally safe
um he would Gaslight and then do you
love bombing afterwards and he there was
never any physical abuse but he would
like throw things down and slam doors
and yell
um and so after asking him to get help
for so long he would always be
remorseful and say that he wanted to
change but he never really did that and
so I started coming home to my own home
that we shared not feeling safe and so
after feeling that way for a year
I eventually ended things because I just
I couldn't keep going and do you hear
how do you hear how what you just
described is almost a blend of your mom
and dad
yes my brother also struggled with
addiction so we can throw that in there
too well it just sounds like however you
have chosen to remember it
um again it's not fair for me in in five
minutes to just throw shade but what we
know about our childhood memories is
they often are way incorrect on either
side of a barbell I had the best
childhood ever except I just
um struggle with disorder eating and
this and this and this and this and it's
like ah well maybe or I had the worst
childhood ever and when you peel it back
it's like well it actually wasn't the
word right so it's often a barbell of
one or the other
man it sounds like y'all grew up in a
home that had some emotional absence in
it and that your bodies are whether it's
looking for drugs or looking for love in
all the wrong places it is you have
bodies that are searching for Connection
in almost desperate ways
[Music]
[Applause]
into another relationship almost
immediately of course you did because
relationships are your drug it's your
drugs
and was it very similar to the one you
just hopped out of
um
well something something happened
recently to where they got upset at an
ATM machine because it ate their cards
and so they kicked the ATM machine and
then they started cussing at it and then
like hitting it and this has never
happened before but I feel like my whole
body went into a state of flight as my
heart started speeding up and I started
shaking and when they came back to the
car I almost felt like unsafe to be in
the car with them like everything in my
body was just telling me to run yeah
because you were in the presence of a
grown-up child
children hit inanimate objects
and curse at inanimate objects children
it's something that I struggle with
though is I'm like okay but behind that
person that's struggling with anger like
there's a lot of pain and do I need to
stay in a relationship and just be
patient while they figure that out but
also that's something that I've found
out is super triggering for me so I
guess I just don't know where to find
the balance of everyone has their
struggles and everyone is in a state of
growth like I know that this person is
trying to grow and try to be better but
when do you know to walk away I I don't
know it number one you're doing a good
job of trusting your body it'll let you
know that you're not safe number two you
can't
um you can't fix everybody
I know over time and that's a pathology
for you that is that is your a childhood
wound that you've been carrying around
that I'll just let's just use dad as an
example that you're still asking
yourself as an adult
what was it about me that was so
unlovable that Dad wouldn't plug into
or you're asking yourself what was it
about me that made mom that mad that she
smashed the cabinets until one of the
drawers came out
and you're continuing to ask that and
ask that an asset and your body is
desperate for connection
and it can get connection through
proxies like alcohol like opiates like
um weed doesn't really provide it but it
shuts down the alarm system
um or hop it into relationship after
relationship after relationship
it's the same drug it's just I mean it's
different drugs but it's the same issue
right for me the how do I know we're
going to grow we're growing together
that it's worth sticking it out is when
somebody invites me into
their hurt their pain
that's when I know I ca I can't keep
Twanda I think or cannonballing into
other people's lives thinking I'm gonna
fix them they didn't invite me in
and the hardest part for someone like
you who loves and cares about other
people you've dedicated your whole life
to it is being romantically involved
with somebody who has not invited you in
and you're looking through the window of
their soul being like I can see it right
there where it hurts and I even went to
grad school I know how to help and they
don't want your help they just want to
yell and kick and scream there will come
a season in their life when either they
have to deal with it or not but they
haven't invited you in
and that sucks that hurts these people
that I've dated do invite me in
okay I feel like they're in a state to
where they invite me in and they always
said that they're sorry and try to make
up for it and I can see behavior is a
language
behavior is a language you knew I was
going to say that behavior is a language
and listen uh
when you're in a relationship with
somebody personal development which is a
phrase that just gives me hemorrhoids
but personal development is something we
do together
for our relationship this world we're
building together
and that's super unpopular and it's
super not Bro Science whatever dude look
I gotta Smash It and Crush no dude
my personal development if I do it all
by myself and my wife does her personal
development all by herself we're going
to end up 2 000 miles away from each
other
so in the morning when I'm up at this
morning I was up at 4 48 in the morning
work and I went to the gym and then I
went on the front porch and did my
assignment that my counselor gave me
that's all personal development but it's
all working towards the goal of me being
a better husband and me being a more
peaceful grown man and me being a better
dad
so it's working in service of not just
working in service of a six-pack or
um cooler muscles or getting my job
promotion see what I'm saying
yeah and when you are working in on you
and you are and he is working on him and
y'all are working on each other I mean
you're working on yourselves towards a
common goal towards a common mission
there's just an innate hey man can you
look at this challenge differently than
me can you see another picture and
that's an invitation in when somebody
sits down with you and it's like oh
you're a counselor you can help me not
be depressed that's not an invitation in
when somebody says oh my gosh I love how
good of a listener you are let me tell
you about all my Pro they're just you
you're being used as a tool to prop them
up
so maybe even feels like an invitation I
think
and you're not gonna like this but I
think you need to detox
I think you need a season of being alone
hanging out with girlfriends
having fun adventures and getting to
know who the heck Abigail is
what does Abigail need what does Abigail
want with her one precious Reckless life
what does she want with all
and I think when you start answering
those questions then you will meet
somebody and your heart will beat a
little bit faster and his will too
and y'all will begin the process of
creating something awesome together not
just co-competing I can fix you I don't
I can crush it I can help fix you I can
dominate it that's just not a recipe for
love that's a recipe for ongoing just
continuing the family Trauma from one
system to another
thank you so much for the call Abigail I
I think you need some peace
who peace
and from there a new relationship will
will grow I'm confident
you're too you're too wonderful of a
person we'll be right back
this show is sponsored by better help
folks take a minute to think about how
much time you spend on yourself it's
easy to get caught up in what people
need from you and want from you and
never think about what you need and then
you end up too stretched out burned out
all of the madness of our current world
resting on your shoulders
look sometimes I put my head down to
work and then realize I haven't had a
meaningful conversation with my wife and
kids all day I get focused on what I'm
doing and I'm running and running and
running
and I don't know how to come back
and therapy is a great way to learn new
skills that make you the best version of
yourself they help you set boundaries
and still have energy left to help
others without leaving yourself behind
so if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
totally online to fit into your schedule
you just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge so find
more balance find Wellness with better
help visit betterhelp.com deloney today
to get 10 off your first month that's a
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we are back let's go out to
Shawnee Oklahoma and talk to Deidre
what's up Deidre
Hi how are you partying how about you
I'm good awesome what's up
um yes I have a question I am a single
mom by choice which means I use the
donor insemination when I had my
daughter okay and she is six years old
and since she was about four years old
she
keeps she knows we're open about how she
was conceived and everything but
she tells a lot of people
I don't have a dad
like random people
um she almost feel like she mom shames
me about it and I tried to explain to
her about families come in all different
shapes and sizes and I had you on
purpose this way
and uh she just she just doesn't get it
and I don't know I don't really know how
to handle it can I ask you some hard
questions yeah promise
yeah we're friends okay
um Are you ashamed of it
no no I I think it's really neat I'm
proud of it why would you care in the
world what a five or six year old has to
say
I just
um maybe not so much shame but you know
you see
you hear about the stigmas of how kids
are raised by you know just a mom and
you know they I don't want to feel like
she's missing out on anything but
um but she is I mean she's missing out
on a dad right
yeah so there is like you don't want
that but there is and I think you can
make a great home in life for her
yes but also it's it's like a uh it's
it's uh both and or an either or right
yeah so I think there's some
truth to that what what
[Music]
here's the hard the hard
reality
is she does have a biological father
somewhere
yes and he was I picked an open donor
okay and she knows that when she's 18.
okay she's allowed to pursue it awesome
okay is that person interested in that
Pursuit when they're 18.
I don't know it's it was through a sperm
bank and I think basically all they do
is just hand them paperwork of what they
have
you know and it's up to you which I will
do whatever she wants sure
but I try to also she's got and we're
friends on like Facebook we have a
private Facebook with the other moms and
I think you got 23 other half siblings
that
you know none of them have a dad and
they're all doing good
allegedly
yeah and please don't put that on her
no because the way you're saying that is
there's 22 other ones that are doing
great and you're the Oddball here and I
don't think that's accurate yeah yeah
that's true
um every one of those kids is going to
wonder who am I
and every one of those kids is gonna
wonder where am I from
Wonder
the question that all children ask which
is
why didn't dad want me and they don't
understand the complexity of of modern
science and technology and the abilities
that we all have now and so those
questions are going to remain and I
think the challenge is not to squash
those questions or to beat them out of a
kid not not literally but figuratively
and to truly honor those questions
because they're existential right I mean
they're they're spiritual in a way
they're they're woven into us right
and so I think it's providing a context
for
safety to ask any and all questions and
I also think it's very important to have
conversations about there are private
conversations
there are private things that we talk
about mother and daughter that are not
to be shared with other adults
and if she chooses to share those things
then she is choosing to opt out of
something that some sort of thing that
she loves like accountability
is that does that make sense
yes I just didn't I didn't understand
I'm
you know we're very I'm very open about
it and so do you understand how how but
let me see it like this she sees a mom
who's incredibly open
talks about anything with a six-year-old
which I think you should be pretty
careful
um there's a difference between openness
and over sharing right my friend Rachel
Cruz says share don't scare there's a
sense of and I think you you nailed it
on the head I picked you of all the kids
in the world I chose you like those
those are that's really important
language
um but you can understand that what she
sees such an open mom talking about
anything and everything and there's no
shame and let's talk about it all that
then all of a sudden there's just some
other adults that she likes and that you
seem to like that she she starts having
the conversation and it's like sure what
are you doing and a six-year-old that's
a hard toggle for a four or five and six
year old
learning the social nuance and what's
cool and what's not cool and here's my
concern my concern is she sees you wince
or she feels your attention or
anxiousness and she will then make that
a problem that she has to solve and that
that's why I asked you the first
question I asked you is Are you ashamed
of this or are you questioning your
choice because
she's gonna absorb that and that
questioning is going to come off as
she's questioning me
see what I'm saying yeah it's more of
how she says it to people it's a it's
like a pity for her I'm the only I'm the
only one who doesn't have a dad no
you're not there are a lot of kids out
there who don't have dads there's a lot
of kids that do have dads that don't
want anything to do with them right yeah
but but she's six and that's hard that's
a hard thing to process for a
six-year-olds
and in her world you and I can tell the
difference between hey that that lady's
just on boyfriend number four and that
guy's on wife number five for her all
her friends have dads
yeah there's a there's a paternal figure
and when you and I even both know all
her friends that's not even true
right but in her six or seven-year-old
little mind it is
yeah and so one of the questions that
young children are constantly asking and
this is a an unconscious question do I
belong do I belong do I belong do I
belong do I belong
and some kids when they feel like they
don't belong they shut the system down
other kids when they feel like they
don't belong they race out to pull the
bullets out of everybody else's gun it
becomes a tool right okay and so you
just have a daughter who's learning from
her mom that you talk about anything
whenever we want and yeah she's
probably doing what my daughter did and
weaponizing that a bit and if she can
get some pity then adults will bend down
and look her in the eye and talk to her
in a quieter voice and say oh but you're
loved and that gives her exactly what
she's looking for so the goal as a
parent is not to shut the questions down
it's to give her those things in other
areas so that she doesn't have to go
searching for it here
yes does that make sense yeah
um does she understand the difference
between private conversations and not
we're working on it okay so I sometimes
have to have to explain to her that you
know things we talk about you know not
all not all people you know at her age
are going to understand and talk about
so don't go sharing with your friends
everything well and and so I remember
one time my son he's probably eight or
nine he said something or did something
and we got in my truck and I looked at
him and said dude will you just be cool
and I could tell on his face I remember
laughing like he has no idea what the
phrase do will you just be cool means he
did not know what that meant and if I
looked at one of my grown-up buddies who
had said the exact thing and I said do
we be cool they would have known yeah I
probably shouldn't have said that and so
I had to be very explicit
so if we talk about something if she
asks a question like
Mommy why don't I have a daddy and
you've answered that question 500 times
yes
um you can go with the answer that
you've given her that's age appropriate
that's not some big over explanation or
some under explanation or some
dishonesty but like a a good straight
forward here's the answer it followed by
and this is a private conversation
between Mom and the little girl that she
loves more than anything
okay what does Private mean
and so my kids know the difference
between secrets and private things
and private is also a word we use for
bathing suit covering areas of our
bodies like what is okay and what's not
okay what's okay to be seen what's okay
for touch all that kind of stuff we have
that conversation so the word private
means not embarrassed or shame private
means incredibly special
okay does that make sense and so yeah
private means something that like I'm
gonna like this is for me you see what
I'm saying and not in a nobody can see
this because it's shameful or gross no
opposite
okay okay that makes sense okay yes um
yes it does but I I want to go back to
the very beginning
I want you to make peace with the world
that you've created
yes
are you at peace with it
of how I decided to have her on my own
no I I'm 100 confident there
that's I'm getting the sense and tell me
I'm off because I could be way out to
lunch here
I'm getting the sense that either it's
more difficult or you're anticipating
these questions or the explanations
aren't working it's just different than
you felt or thought or hoped for
I didn't think it would happen this soon
okay kind of things happen when they're
like 13.
oh man okay that's very smart for her
age and talks like a little adult and
takes things in like well don't make it
is because it's just me and her but when
she was like four and she started asking
kind of questions I'm like okay where's
the book for this and you know because
this is a simple I mean this is a unique
situation not everyone in Shawnee you
know has done this
I can imagine that number is very small
um yes but uh there is a couple of great
books I don't have them off top of my
head um on Amazon that you can find in
that are just good reading books
um that walk through this
um and
it may be great if you can maybe these
Facebook groups can help if you can find
somebody who's a teenager or an adult
who was conceived this way that would be
able to talk to your daughter and in
some sort of high level
relationship kind of way it might be
good to have some like a light out ahead
of this path here for her okay and it
might be good for you to have some
parents down the road have you spent
some time with them
um other women that have done this
um yeah some of them are they're a
little on the the far end
the side almost like man haters a lot of
times yeah and so it's kind of hard to
find one that you know just did this
because it was her time and just didn't
have the best relationships to wait for
the right one gotcha
so I think I think it's worthy of
finding one or two mentors that you can
have on text thread that you can text
and be like whoa my eight-year-old just
asked this and they'll be like yeah it's
gonna be weird
um I think that's super super valuable
for you
okay
let me give you one last little tidbit
she can never become your best friend
okay she can't carry the weight of the
adult decisions that you have made and
have to make moving forward
right 25 is the cut off that I give
folks
okay 21 you can take your kid to get a
tattoo and a drink that's fine oh that's
fine 25 is when you can transition like
now we're we're peers we're buddies and
there's still that weird like we're not
gonna talk about sex we're gonna talk
about some of that stuff but we can we
can talk about a lot more in a friend
kind of way but man she can't handle
that that weight of that relationship
she needs to see her mom have grown-up
mom friends
okay that's a really important gift for
her
okay but let her ask all questions
they're all okay and they're all worthy
and they're all good let's work really
hard on Upstream where are moments that
you are putting your hands on her face
during a day hopefully every day yes
there are moments when you're getting
down on eye level and or getting down on
all fours and just you're playing Wolf
Pack 2 or whatever weird thing she's
imagining or when there's no talking and
she's just tired and you'll just color
together next to each other
where are those moments constantly
popping up popping up and they're going
to be intentional wear those calms so
that it's not she doesn't have to have
these big emphatic dramatic moments to
gain adult attention and don't care and
adult love they're gonna come along the
way and she's gonna push the boundaries
and she's going to find out what's cool
and what's not cool and she's gonna have
to learn social situations and things
like that and that's where the
conversation about privacy is really
important
but all told
it's both and
you're a mother who loves her daughter
and you chose her
and she's not gonna have dad there's
both of those things both those things
are true and she does have a dad that
she's going to meet someday
Maybe
so understand there's gonna be a lot of
complexity there there's gonna be a lot
of stuff that it's gonna be different
than a quote-unquote traditional
childhood and I know it's super hip and
cool to be like there's no such thing
there is such thing and so understand
that she's going to have ups and downs
and hard questions and easy questions
and softballs and Nolan Ryan fastballs
that's just part of parenting and it's
always
always comes earlier than you think
all the questions all the hard ones that
come earlier than you think thank you so
much for the call Deidre we'll be right
back
all right we're back let's go out to
Atlanta Georgia home of the second place
behind the Astros Braves what's up Brian
hey John how are you thank you for
taking my call you got it what's up
brother
got a two-part question I'm hoping you
can help me with Let's Do It um am I
wrong for asking my wife to go to
counseling with me and if not
how do I encourage her that we need it
and the back story to it is uh this is
my second marriage been married almost
four years
um have three teenage boys and then a
two-year-old daughter
um about eight months ago started
noticing a change and knew something was
off and then back in January
um discovered she was talking to an ex
for about
six seven eight months
um said it was nothing physical don't
think it was after uh doing some
investigating and uh she just basically
thinks that I should forgive her Let It
Go and move on with life
have you been cheated on before
uh no
okay
um
to answer your first question no
if your marriage is going wonderful
if your marriage is hanging on by a
spider's web
asking the person you care about can we
go see a professional that can help us
either take this relationship to the
next level to
insulate it for things that are gonna
come because things are gonna come or to
save this thing no asking to your
partner to go see a therapist to go see
a marriage counselor is is one of the
highest forms of Honor I think
I asked my wife recently and she said ah
thank God I was about to ask you so no I
don't I think that's a something that is
of high honor
she doesn't get a vote
into how you quote unquote feel
she doesn't get a vote as to how
um you
should respond
will she sending photos back and forth
uh yes there was photos you know she
basically said
uh you know we're good friends you know
I didn't tell you because I know you
wouldn't let me be friends with somebody
at the opposite sex
iest gasoline she's just trying to make
you the bad guy here what kind of photos
uh
uh her in a bikini
um bro Brian you know
you know
oh yeah I'm I'm not I'm not an idiot you
know I I know there was there was more
there than just friends because I don't
have a female friend that I would send
myself out in the out at the pool
pictures I know
yes you know Brian you know
right so it's one of those things where
I don't know it's uh
like it was obviously more than just
friends you know you have I'm not
friends with I mean I'm friends with my
ex because we have kids but
all our text messages are with my wife
included in a group text message that's
very very wise that's very wise just
because I don't want that situation to
come up yeah you know and and I told her
you know when we sat down and talked
about it I'm like you know
it may not have been physical but it's
still an emotional affair absolutely and
she doesn't she doesn't agree that it's
an emotional affair she's like it was
just friends I'm like if I said if you
caught me talking to another woman
behind your back sending her pictures of
me in the gym or me you wouldn't just go
oh okay y'all are just friends I am or
her sending you bikini photos or topless
photos and being like nah we're just
friends and you'd be like all right no
no right you're not crazy um
um so I'm assuming you asked her to go
to counseling and she said no
she's a very private person
um she's gonna be private all by herself
right
because
you don't trust her
and you shouldn't
and she is not doing anything to regain
that trust other than blame you
for how you should be feeling it's not
that big a deal oh my gosh I knew you're
gonna act like this all that gaslighting
bullcrap
right and you have a two-year-old and
you've been through hell before with a
divorce you know how awful it is
and my fear for you is you're gonna
think so little of your own self-worth
you're going to shut this sucker down
and just deal with what comes
and that's that's kind of the reason
that what made me call you is there is
zero Intimacy in the in the marriage
um she blames it on the kid and you know
her body
um the one that she's sending pictures
up to her ex
right and that's uh you know the uh and
that's that's what I've said and you
know basically she has said if I don't
let it go then I need to let her go
um
wow bro do you hear what I mean
yeah oh no I know I'm just trying to
what what like obviously you can't just
convince somebody to go to counseling if
they're not going to go They're not
going to go Ryan she's about your
marriage Brian Brian she has left your
marriage
this is a common move she's trying to
make this whole thing your fault so that
you will ultimately leave
and that's that's exactly what I told my
my pastor is how I feel that's not I'm
telling you right now she is done
and she is coming up with excuse after
excuse she's withholding intimacy or not
going to a medical doctor or a therapist
to try to heal her body heal her mind
hear her soul it's not uncommon for
there to be intimacy issues with a
two-year-old in the house that's very
common but what's not common is just
throwing her hands up and blaming you
for it
right well she said she's gonna go uh to
the doctor to uh
see what's going on and behavior is a
language
and she can say everything she wants but
her behavior is telling you she ain't
going
and now she's making ultimatums and
threats if you don't if you don't shove
your feelings in a box and bury them in
the backyard
I'm out of here
and then when you can't do that because
you have too much you have too much
self-worth
and you value the picture of marriage
that your sons are seeing you value what
love and responsibility looks like for
your two-year-old she's gonna leave and
blame you
he was crazy
he wouldn't let it go
and and that's that's kind of what I've
said is like
it's not
it's not good for the kids to see this
and it's not good for our daughters see
this because this isn't what marriage is
yes you are correct
so I don't I mean is it something where
I should just be like hey
if you don't want to go to counseling we
probably need to go another Direction I
I will never be the person to tell you
to leave your wife
I don't know you well enough I don't
know her well enough unless it is a uh
an incredibly abusive situation
no it's it's not that we get along
um you know of course you do she's
getting she's got the
she's got things taken care of
right yeah she's not dumb
she's not not at all very smart yes
if I'm in your shoes what I would do is
I would a start seeing somebody on my
own
I would go call a counselor on my own I
do I talked to uh a pat one of my former
pastors that I want you to go see a
clinical counselor
okay
uh I want you to call local counselor in
your area begin to sit down and work
through it because my guess is why did
you get divorced the first time
um
it was kind of oil and water
um the crazy thing is we get to we get
along better now as co-parents than we
did as parents yeah it's actually I hear
that with some regularity once the
pressure of the marriage is gone people
act like adults and then they act like
grown-ups and they realize oh I don't
have to choose misery but
it's after everything's all wrapped up
um
when you say oil and water I don't
really buy that what else was there
oh there there really wasn't anything
else was there anger and rage and people
treating each other bad or yeah I mean
obviously we we fought a lot and I mean
nothing physical ever but it was just
always
uh
always arguing fighting
um
it just was was not a not a good
situation okay I don't want to blame
that on well I was oil and she was water
because if I was to drill down I think
me and my wife were oil and water but we
made a commitment and we figured it out
see what I'm saying right and so at the
end of the day there were some choices
made
probably my guess would be the choices
were
Brian you need to shut your mouth
and that got hard is that fair
yes that's fair yeah and here we are
again
right and like an earlier caller you
married your unfinished business and
we're right back in the same boat
right um have you sat down with your
current wife and asked her
um
to build a life with you
yeah and she you know she says she's
done with it she's moving forward uh she
wants us to move forward
um you know she's
she's been apologetic but it's one of
those things where it's you know it's
it's still in the back your mind you
know she says she's when we talk about
it she says she feels like I'm putting
myself on a pedestal and putting herself
you know below me because
she was in the situation not me and you
know I'm like I'm not stupid enough to
know that I couldn't have easily been in
that situation that you put yourself in
you know she said she made a mistake you
know she was at fault it should have
never happened that's all true that's
all true and good for her good for her
for owner name
but she's not
she's weaponizing the apology
She's Not Taken full accountability
right if I do that same thing
and I tell my wife hey I really screwed
up I put myself in a position and I
compromised our marriage I didn't go all
the way but man I screwed up screwed up
what does rebuilding trust look like now
because we got to build something new
that's the path forward the path forward
cannot be so you just need to suck it up
and get over and I said I was
you should just divorce me
come on man right and that and and
that's what I like she says forgiveness
means forgetting and I'm like that's not
that's not what forgiveness means I'm
like I if I was in your situation I
would I would say the same thing I would
be like hopefully you forget it
right there is another man holding
pictures of your wife wearing almost
nothing or nothing depending on which
ones you actually saw and that she
deleted
of course it's going to be in your mind
well and he's married so there's a you
know there's a whole other element yeah
that's I mean that's getting into his
head in the world I wouldn't even spend
a second in that world
yeah you've got enough trouble on your
own in your own house
right here's the deal you're not crazy
and when you're with a master gaslighter
you can just start to think that the sky
is actually
red and green
because they just say it so much but
you're not crazy
the question you need to get to the
bottom of is is that it is does your
wife want to be married to you or not
and marriage looks like working really
hard to regain Intimacy in the house not
just sexual but to regain connectivity
intimacy uh I mean uh being married
looks like waking up every day and
taking a knee and saying how can I love
you more
and hoping to God that you do the same
for her
right marriage looks like
um I hurt you and I'm so sorry
when you're ready
I'll do whatever it takes
not oh my gosh are you bringing this up
again you're the worst you should just
divorce me oh come on dude you know I
mean
right so let me let me close with this I
know what I'm saying is hard
I also know that you know everything
that I'm saying
and there's something in your spirit
that does not want to confront the
reality of your marriage right now
and my guess is like I said earlier
you've been through hell with divorce
again and the thought of going through
that again is so terrible
you can avoid it at all cost even if it
just means biting your lip and getting
through it
and I can't tell you one way or the
other man I don't know what you went
through last time I don't know what that
cost you last time both psychologically
and physically and financially I don't
know
I know that your house is cold right now
and I know that you're really really
lonely
and the person that you looked in the
eye and said before your friends and
family of God I I will forever
and she said it back
it's not coming back
so you all have to decide are we going
to build something completely new and
you need to ask her point blank is she
going to be a part of building something
new with you and if so here's what this
is going to look like
here's what you need this to look like
and then honestly you're gonna ask her
what does she need this to look like
then you'll have to move forward or
y'all got to have some hard
conversations about what comes next
I wish you the absolute best moving
forward my brother please let me know
how those conversations go but it's time
to stop circling and circling and
circling and it's time to Turn All the
Lights On turn the music off party's
over the dance is stop
we need to sit down at this table let
all the glitter on the floor land
and then we got to figure out what our
relationship is is going to be worth
moving forward
hard man but I'll be with you every step
of the way we'll be right back
[Music]
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right we are back as we wrap up
today's show
um on those awkward days when Kelly will
wear super short shorts down her left
leg you can see the Burr Lake tattoo she
is a Justin Timberlake fanatic
um and so it doesn't surprise me that
she picked today's song
Crimea River
Crimea River what great song he's such a
good tune and it goes like this
you were my son you were my Earth
but you didn't know all the ways I loved
you no
so you took a chance and made other
plans but I bet you didn't think they'd
come Crashing Down
you don't have to say what you did I
already know I found out from
him
that's the worst way to find out
now there's just no chance for you and
me they're never there'll never be
don't don't make you sad about it
you told me you loved me why'd you leave
me all alone you told me you need me
when you call me on the phone girl I
refuse you must have me confused with
some other guy the bridges were burned
now it's your turn to cry cry me a river
what a great song listen America Cry Me
a River just kidding don't cry find some
friends go do something kind stay in
school no new drugs all that stuff love
y'all bye